First off, let's look at a typical method call. As you know, all the way on the
left is the object, on which the method is called. Next comes the name of the
method. And the values, that we supply to the method, are called the arguments.
That's just a technical term. This particular method call is called with the
arguments 20 and 0. Let's have a look at another method call, again here is the
object, the method name. This particular method call has no arguments, there's
just nothing between the two parenthesis. But this method call returns an
answer, it returns the number of pixels in the picture. That answer, or as we
say, that return value, is then stored in the variable that you see on the
left. What about the method call up here? This method call has no return value,
it simply, carries out an action, namely to grow the picture.